"Thor: Love and Thunder" has double the Thor
action with Jane Foster joining Odin's son
– but for many fans, the real star of the
show is the man who's trying to burn it all
down.
Warning: spoilers for "Thor: Love and Thunder"
ahead.
In Marvel movies, the hero is typically only
as good as the villain they have to go up
against.
And in "Thor: Love and Thunder," we see the
god of thunder battle one of his most imposing
foes to date.
In the past, Thor's biggest battles have often
been family affairs.
With the exception of Malekith the Dark Elf
and Thanos the Mad Titan, Thor has spent most
of his time battling his siblings, namely
Loki and Hela.
He even had his issues with his father, before
he grew up a little and proved himself to
be worthy.
But now, he needs some fresh blood to go up
against, and he gets it in the form of Gorr
the God Butcher.
Gorr's issue with Thor is fairly straightforward.
He felt betrayed by his own god, so once he
got hold of the Necrosword, he vowed to kill
every god out there.
Thor is no exception, and based on some of
the scenes we get, he's pretty efficient in
his god-killing.
He manages to defeat some truly formidable
foes before turning his attention to Eternity
and getting that coveted wish to take out
every god once and for all.
He may be the bad guy, but he's more than
made his mark on fans, who can't help but
praise what's arguably one of the best villains
in a Marvel movie ever.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" opens with a sequence
showing Gorr's tragic backstory as he wanders
the desert with his daughter, doomed to die.
When he finally stumbles upon his god, he's
heartbroken to realize that the god doesn't
care about him or his dead daughter.
In response, he vows to kill every god out
there for revenge.
It's a heartbreaking sequence.
Who can't empathize with a man who's just
lost his daughter?
And fans seem to think this makes Gorr one
of the better antagonists to come out of Marvel
Studios.
One Redditor kicked off a discussion on the
topic, saying,
"This was the first time, in a verrry long
time, that I actually felt the menace of the
villain and jeopardy of the characters.
And it was the first time I felt that I wanted
to see more of the villain's adventures."
A ton of people agreed, with many wishing
they had gotten to see more of Gorr in the
flick.
One user stated,
"Definitely wish we could have seen at least
one more scene of God Butchery."
There may very well be more Gorr moments on
the horizon, somewhere in the special features
of the movie's home release.
In an interview with IGN, Bale mentioned how
one particular scene had to be left on the
cutting room floor, potentially for being
a little bit too "extreme" – so anyone hoping
for more god butchery may well get their wish
granted in the months to come.
"I'm counting on that."
Gorr likely won't come back to the MCU anytime
soon for another adventure, considering the
film's ending, but deleted scenes would be
more than welcome if it means fans can spend
a little bit more time with the surprisingly
compelling God Butcher.
In "Thor: Love and Thunder," Gorr's health
gradually deteriorates due to his use of the
Necrosword.
By the time he reaches Eternity, he's nearly
at death's door, and with his final promised
wish, he brings his daughter back to life.
At the end of the day, Gorr's really just
a family man.
He just wanted his family to be safe, which
is par the course for the Gorr readers know
from the comics.
Gorr's comic origin story is similar to the
one we see in the film.
While he initially believes in the worthiness
of the gods, he soon loses hope due to the
loss of his wife and children.
Unlike the film, his final child is a boy
in the comics, but his faith isn't enough,
and his child quickly perishes.
Gorr is a relatively new addition to comics
lore.
He made his first appearance in "Thor: God
of Thunder #2" in 2012, and he's gone on to
have numerous spars with the likes of the
Asgardian.
For those wishing for more adventures with
Gorr, the pages of a comic will be your best
bet.
There are plenty of folks who would like to
see more of the antagonist, as evidenced by
one Redditor, who wrote,
"Honestly I could watch a Gorr movie.
Just the opening with his daughter made me
sympathize with him.
Such an interesting character."
Gorr's return to the MCU is unlikely, despite
characters having come back from the dead
before.
But if you want more Gorr, you'll have to
head over to your local comic shop.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.